in the 12 days since
russia launched this illegal and brutal
assault
the world has come together in
solidarity with the indomitable people
of ukraine
last week 141 countries nearly
three-quarters of the entire membership
of the united nations voted to condemn
putin's war
and 39 countries including the uk canada
and the netherlands
voted to refer putin's actions to the
international criminal court
this is the largest such action the
court has ever seen and will allow the
chief prosecutor to
open an investigation to ensure putin
cannot commit these crimes with impunity
as ukrainians resist russia's onslaught
with courage and tenacity the
international community must aid their
struggle in every way that we can we
will only succeed if the whole
international community
moves together
with the same spirit of unity that we've
seen in recent days
justin and mark and i have been
discussing that today and later this
afternoon i'm going to be speaking to
the leaders of the united states france
and germany
further to coordinate our actions
to aid these efforts today the uk is
joining our dutch and canadian friends
to mobilize more practical and sustained
support for ukraine
our new international ukraine support
group will coordinate the efforts of the
international community to provide
long-term and unwavering assistance
now and in the future and we will be
encouraging more countries to join us
this is the moment for ukraine's friends
to create a coalition of humanitarian
economic and defensive military support
to ensure
that putin fails and that's why today
i'm announcing a further
175 million pounds of uk aid for ukraine
100 million dollars of which will be
provided directly to the ukrainian
government
this brings the total uk support
announced during this crisis to around
400 million pounds
after 12 days it's already clear that
putin has made a miscalculation
he has underestimated the ukrainians
their heroic resistance he's
underestimated their leader and he has
underestimated the unity of the west and
we will continue as colleagues to do
everything we can to strengthen that
unity in the days ahead to ensure that
putin fails in this catastrophic
invasion of ukraine thank you very much